a steady stream of supplies greets those
battling the eye-watering smoke and ash
to reach survivors it's a small token
for a community that's lost so much from
rescue teams who know all too well
what they've endured for volunteers like
these Greek Life Guards it's been an
unrelenting few days here when the fires
broke out they took to the waters
desperately searching for survivors then
came the search for bodies now they're
joining the many hundreds of volunteers
handing out food and water to those in
need those still scouring the waters can
do little but wait with dozens still
missing fears are growing that many who
sought refuge in the waters instead lost
their lives we're looking for the bodies
now if they are more in the water it is
a difficult job these because we know
that everything we find now it's only
facade and you know but good for the
people who have the relief that they
found the people their beloved yes at
least Palos la paz was among those who
helped residents flee to the water
before saving himself the horror of that
night forever etched in his mind me and
with the other guys I'm gonna read the
port and put some people some citizens
out of the cultu gonna see I see some
guys with one girl wearing that because
the fire that I can two cuts very bad
things here he's turned his bar into a
makeshift food bank another beacon of
hope for those in need this is a
community whose resilience is
breathtaking in the face of a tragedy
the true scale of which is yet unknown